hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swish what a lad podcast
as always i'm very grateful to have
swish on board with water lad it is such
a cool platform and for such a great
cause with up to 70 of proceeds going to
kiwi kids charities so how it works if
you don't know if you haven't clicked on
the link yet is you can choose any
sports star who is on swish and get a
personalized video message from them for
yourself or a friend or anyone really
and in a few days
that star will have sent you your very
own personalized video message there are
plenty of lads on there including guys
who have been on waterload as well
including all blacks such as bowdoin
barrett lesterfanganuku aaron smith and
of course our recent waterless star sam
kane and just for listening to water lad
you can get 15 off your order by using
the code what a lad and to order head
over to hayswish.com
or click the link in the description
below
also the great pomerose coffee have
created the perfect coffee bean for any
lad and they've packaged it up as what a
lad coffee
i know you all love your coffee so go
and order yourself some of the best
beans on the market roasted freshly here
in nelson and available in espresso
plunger or whole bean however you like
to make it and you can get an extra 20
off your order by using the code lad 03
that's laden capitals oh three i'll
leave a link in the description below
for easy access for you
finally the lad absolutely tim bateman
he has an offer for you all so listen up
to this cheers jimmy my name's tim
bateman and i've been a professional
rugby player for the last 17 years
my plan for life after rugby was to get
into the well-being and recovery
industry so i built ostudio new
zealand's largest well-being and
recovery center
despite the challenges of covert we've
seen consistent growth in our business
and we've decided to expand ostudio
throughout new zealand and abroad
it's an exciting time for the wellbeing
industry and we're looking for top lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
studio
if you're interested head to ostudio dot
co dot nz slash lad to inquire
back to the show
[Music]
oh what a tune well today guys i have
one of the genuine good guys of new
zealand rugby one of the kindest caring
lads you'll ever meet and a bloody good
player as well he's a true wellingtonian
who played most of his career in
wellington for the lions and the
hurricanes where he was a very
influential figure for both of those
sides he also reached the ultimate
heights of the game in new zealand
playing for the all blacks and he had a
stint over in france with arjen he is
one of the greats john swolger welcome
mate
cheers brother thanks for having me bro
mate thanks for coming on mate some
journey i'm looking through your career
again last night you've had you had a
hell of a career yeah well i was just
blessed you know and just coming from um
has been one of the
the good stories you know because uh
jerry collins was pretty much our
our light and our figure that we
followed so um it was good to have
someone like that um just to make sure
that anyone coming after him
we followed suit and just giving 100
but no one jerry he would have smoked us
if we didn't listen to him so
we did everything we could to make sure
he was happy
no it's awesome to have another um i
guess role model for those kids in
porido and in yourself and i know you're
giving so much back to the community at
the moment um for those who don't know
what you're up to give us a bit of an
insight into what you're up to now so at
the moment just happened at um namira
and um
and putty over in um wellington college
there's a few uh kids from poriru that
are out there my son was lucky enough to
to get in and
go through there but on the other side
is um trying to put a program together
with a few of my old school mates just
to try and
upskill the the next generation in terms
of you know career path but also using
sports as a
you know as a vehicle just to bring them
all together and hopefully we can find
what they want to do in life and see the
world like uh like we did it's so cool
to see you giving back so much to the
community um and like you pity nimir
helping out at wellington college giving
back to them those kids must be stoked
having three genuine superstars of the
game um coaching them yeah
we think creatures aside it's good you
know we get to
know the kids um you know in a different
level but once we're once boots on
switch on time um that's when we just
turn into no not me and putty but nemo
sort of tested
slaughter so
um we just let the general do his thing
and as uh as the lieutenants we just
watch and support what we can do and
then hopefully try and like taper down
some of the stuff that he's putting on
the kids but you can see um
the boys afterwards they feel the pain
but also can i can see what it does
moving forward is that sort of
conditioning stuff that he gets goes
hard at them with uh it's conditioning
it's smashing each other it's down and
ups all the good stuff that uh you saw
well for those that were coached by
jimmy dressler would know what i mean by
this um so there was no easy day you had
to earn it
and you had to also earn your rest so if
you didn't earn your risk you keep going
until you're dead
but it's good yeah it's a good um and
different style from these guys you know
what they've had previously so
it's just showing them what the next
level looks like all right it's crack up
and what's pity like as a coach
he's melo is he's just like a player
like when he was playing he who he'll
say his birt
critique here and there and um
and just go from um you know trying to
upskill them as much as he can but in a
different way
so it's a good balance off from the
mirror and um
and pity yeah and what's your sort of
style what sort of approach do you take
oh
one bit of a mixture there's some i try
to be hard
in terms of um making sure that they
listen to what i say but
um also
i'll go on the mellow side too just to
try and tell them that you can always
make mistakes in there that's the only
way you can learn and then if they keep
on doing it that's when i'm like bro
yeah on the line
let's go
but yeah it's a mixture of of the the
hardness and also the soft part of it
but
as we grow we learn as well so
yeah just like the kids yeah 100 oh very
cool no doubt wellington college will be
a force this year then but as always in
the podcast i'm always interested to
hear um how the journey started for
um i guess so give us a bit of a rundown
on your upbringing okay so
before i play rugby i was just into
soccer you know i don't know why but
i was just
what my friends were doing at the time
um
um
we were
two schools that i was in a catholic
school
before finally a week but i hated it
because uh
we could have they were uniform i looked
across the road and they were wearing
mufti so lucky enough i got my mom and
dad to switch me over and they sort of
backfired on me because when i did go to
college all those guys they were there
and their first day were actually doing
me a bit of grief
i remembered me because i was like one
of the big kids at that time
and that's when i sort of started my
rugby path was when one of my good mates
ran past my house asked him what he was
doing and then he goes i'm just going
to sign up
didn't know what he already meant went
for a run
and then
joined the northern united rugby club
there that day
and i told my dad two days later that i
joined can you pay for my fees give me a
picture and then yeah then i just
enjoyed it after that only because i was
i was sort of good at hitting people but
then got used to getting hit myself
so it was uh it was a big difference but
you know it was one of those you know
baptism by fire just to go and get
wasted in and go from there and then
yeah i started enjoying it
um went through the ranks back at school
in um bishopville college which is known
now and then i started
enjoying it made the reps at 16 um and
then you know the rest was history after
that wait what were you like at soccer i
can't imagine you thanks okay bro i was
only those the ones that just give me
the ball and i picked it up as if i was
the goalie and i'll be like halfway and
then pick it up and go no you can't
touch it and i'll shut up and i was just
trying to hoof it as if i was the man
trying to do like a box kick
but yeah at that time i was skinny i
think that was the only time i was
skinny back then until i got into rugby
i had to be [ __ ] because the boys i
was like
um
going up against right they were like
smoking me as like oh that's sweet but
because i had the footwork of soccer
sorry about that um you know
and i just kept on sticking on me and
then they go now run the street we're on
the street and that's what we always did
at lunchtime so we ran a straight bang
sort of got boring and then we just
stood turned running straight into a
proper rugby game
and play time lunch time and that was
sort of like what we did right through
uh college life so were you not always
one of the big guys
nah
nah i wasn't it wasn't until i got to
maybe
um fifth form which is year 11 now i
beefed up over the summer i just
yeah they said yeah beef up but i don't
know beef wasn't me get bulky so i just
ate all summer and came into
your uh
year 11 and then i was like
bro everyone was like lean and mean of
like oh what the hell
so yeah i had to go do some running this
there's a road out here um called the
old road
i didn't put it all so i went through
there a few times because no one can see
you so i suffered back then a few times
how much weight did you put on
oh
let's just say i've put on maybe
close to 40.
there's someone that's a big summer
bro because i went from like maybe 65 70
to like over like 110.
what the heck
that's when i went from number eight to
prop
everybody that was a blessing in
disguise because i ended up being uh you
know
ended up enjoying uh uh prop as well so
yeah i stayed there i was like yeah i'm
not moving no way i'm gonna try and get
further than this right stuff does
yeah
and you mentioned potty door what was it
like um growing up in pottery door as a
teenager uh it was mean man it was tough
but it was mean it was one of those
places like people would just go to to
the park play around and you know
when to get home as if you hear a
whistle from your parents or auntie and
uncle or when the street lights come up
once it's turned on then you know all
right time to get home if you don't get
home before it's actually dark then you
know what you're gonna get it's not just
a whack it's a see all four walls in
your room
[Laughter]
yeah so but i was good you know i
learned some good lessons uh
back then and it sort of um
stared me in the right direction because
i would have been a naughty kid if i
didn't did you have a big family
um i had five sisters
wow and just you as a brother yeah so i
sort of got used to looking after girls
growing up but at the same time i had to
leave the house so i can catch up with
my cousins because
bro being at home i had to cook clean
after my mom
she'll do that she'll tell me make sure
i do all this for my sisters i'm like
are you serious
really
but i had to be in a brother
the oldest in the family at the time um
just to make sure i cleaned up and got
everything ready for for the sisters but
when they got to their age that was when
all right they can do their own stuff
and i'll just go and do mine so what age
is that
oh i learned how to cook when i was
seven yeah well seven
not at the time bro
i was like what the hell i have to do
this man and i see my friends outside
playing outside and i'm i'm like waving
to them through the windows they're [ __ ]
i wish i was out there
i don't know
gotta do my chores sure what was your
go-to meal as a seven-year-old whoa okay
it was either
bread tomato sauce
and sugar at that time
because
yeah bro
i grew up learning how to make my own
food you know this you're 40 kgs
there's your 40 kgs bro and then there's
other times that um
um you know the the oil from the um the
leftover chicken or roast that you have
the night before
i'll heat that up get my butter and
bread and then i just scooped it and
that was me man that was my go-to bro
if i wasn't if i wasn't hungry after
that or fall after that then
i'll look for some more stuff what can i
make what can i make
oh yeah let's try this oh [ __ ] okay
let's eat that
kind of choice
i was an interesting guy even when we
had our pre-matches and all that stuff
all the boys were looking at me like
what the hell is that because
just food man just worry about yourself
came the food i'll just
yeah i know
and in terms of rugby obviously you said
you moved into the front row
you're picked up by new zealand under
16s 2a so i mean you obviously had
pretty rapid growth yeah uh it was just
i was lucky enough to have a guy named
um ella mueller at that time
um he he just got us to he just told me
just to play my game which i loved the
physical stuff like running cleaning and
tackling but i that's i didn't know how
to
like you know the work right off it off
the ball
you know so i learned the hard way
through that
and that's why he got me to get fit and
then by the end of the year i was at a
good weight i was i was foot enough to
do what i had to do and
yeah then i was just blessed to make new
zealand 16 that year and then
i went through from that but at the same
time my first rugby game that year well
i played nehemiah the first time
it was cole versus via that the yeah and
that was our first proper game that's
when him and this guy named aura rash um
broke my sternum
i was like bro
i don't know i don't want to be ferrari
anymore
but it was a yeah like i said it was a
better
baptism of fire bro i learned the hard
way bro
but i loved it in the end so when you
first made that under 16 is that when
you first thought this could be a career
path yeah
once uh once i first met the um the
wellington team was like wow this is me
because we were given gears i was like
the hell did i ever get kids growing up
you know unless it was from my
grandparents and whatnot you know but
this had like uh like the emblem of [ __ ]
this is me and then i was lucky enough
to play well in their tournament they
made um
sixteens and for their silver friend got
me after that i was like [ __ ] this
doesn't mean if i can
keep doing this
this could be something that i can do
moving forward and that was my whole
focus from then on was trying to try to
make new zealand team every year while i
was at school
and that then the all blacks came into
play like wow i
i want to be all black
farsah more but i want to be an oblique
you know so and you mentioned jerry
collins earlier about him being sort of
the potty of god did he have much of an
influence on you and your rugby career
at that age yes
this is the first time i met
jerry that leading up into that um that
year
um he found out i was um part of the
like the new zealand squad before and
then he goes to me um
he goes to i met him at the creek i just
went um because my mom told me to go
have a um go get a feed before i went
for a run
i did that
and when when i got a pie and a drink
uh soft drink was like a dollar
at the time the man pulled up
and he looked at me oh he winded down
his window and i was like oh [ __ ] this
is jerry oh what's up man and he looked
at my he looked at me looked at my my
pie my drink told me what the [ __ ] is
that
uh my lunch because
drop it
and knowing me because i've been taught
never to waste my food right i looked at
him looked at my food and he told me to
drop it
that was like heartbreaking for me
so i dropped it
and he looked at me and you know as i
dropped it off i was like [ __ ]
i was angry i was like i'm gonna knock
you out bro
but you know no one's gonna do that to
jerry
and he just goes to me yep run um go for
a run okay yep i will you guys know run
now let's go well i run put it all
and then i say hey i'll get him but at
the time i only thought puerido was the
creek right
but then found out later on
during my run this was 4 30 in an
afternoon during my run
i found out that the mall was part of
poriru
wappi was part of puerido
uh pukaroo bay i was nowhere i was gonna
run there uh the bay
and all the way or back so it took me
six hours i think what
you know so i ran for six hours because
of that dick
i was gathered bro
but at the same time i was more kind of
i had to drop my bloody food because it
was a freaking mr cheese pie and a
raspberry drink
i was like man
but because yeah so that's how i learned
that porrido was a bigger place
16 years old just from one guy had you
not met jerry before nah like i'll see
him but i was too scared to go and talk
to him because like bro
at that time unless she knew him then of
course you're not gonna go up to him but
he was throwing chairs yeah so how did
he know you or did he just hear that
you're a rugby player yeah he knew
because it was a um i think he just
keeps tabs on all the boys from puerido
oh yeah but also he had um the coach i
had at 16 was the same coach he had as
well so
i don't know if they were communicating
or whatever but man the minute i saw him
pull up yes hey what's up bro i was
nervous and then drop it
bro
and then go for run oh [ __ ] six hours
later ah damn it
i missed my assignment so i played um i
told my teacher because i had to do
assignment that that night i told my
teacher nah jerry collins told me how to
run because i don't care did he tell you
to get for a run yes he did because
did you listen yeah at least i'll get a
hiding
oh yeah so i used him as an excuse
of why i didn't do my assignment that
night oh that's so good so then what was
your pathway from school once you left
college what was your pathway into the
professional rugby game from there uh i
was lucky enough to be in the um the
wellington academy uh when i was in
school with um and i had my best mate um
anthony perensi there was there was
there and then nemia puri and all those
guys were all part of that tommy ellison
and there so we had a good bunch
in that group and then all of us were
striving to be you know
and all black because that was always
something that they wanted us to
to aim for you know always aim for the
sky and if you miss it then you know
even better so
yeah so we got into that went through
all the age grades which was 19 and 21s
or cults at that time
and then the lions was the next step but
also had eighth grade new zealand
as well so now it was good good trips
you know i'll see that yeah yeah what
what was it like playing um in the new
zealand 21 age groups obviously you do
get to travel probably the first time
you traveled overseas you're with some
of your best mates like you mentioned
wearing the silver fern um you're living
the good life what was it like how old
was me bro uh it was good because you
got to meet other people from other you
know other areas and how they operate
and how they
um do things
some some are a bit weird because it's
just the way they they grew up in there
but
in the environment and then you have the
the auckland boys are like always out
there real noisy i'm like shakers and we
were just in between
a lot but i was good bro like um
it was just more just
i want to say a bunch of street kids but
it felt like you know um especially from
us uh uh the island boys and that coming
from you know the our background
to a
environment like that we're like wow
this is mean bro
this is awesome blah blah blah and then
we go muck around do a bit but the
minute you put on the the jersey
it's like
you're going from your background to
like this professional guy that
it's not even you you know but because
that their jersey
makes you change
it's like it's one of those feelings
that no
this is me bro i don't want this to ever
stop
you know so
it was good it was good and you guys
carved it up in that tournament two-way
smoke south africa in the final but you
guys had a stacked team when you look
back on it oh
bro
it was crazy yeah
but it was led by um um benatinga so he
um
that's why we thought that he because he
was captain at the time that he'll be
like you know the all this um the
staunch guy everyone needs to listen to
him
although he was a crowd cop that's why
he made it made out that trip so fun you
know real enjoyable because he made us
be us
not hey that shush no listen to this
blah blah blah he goes nah when we train
we train but when we think just be you
yeah so that's why we were
we enjoyed it so because we did that we
were able to express ourselves on the
field
you know if i was good to i got to meet
um
uh ben frank's
for those that know him bro
he's
like to the book guy man but
he was also good like so
i started to see the softer side of him
and it was cool
even though he took my spot i was like
it was good you know it was the
environment that
you play for each other you compete
against each other but also
um whoever takes it sweet you just
support them and that's how i learned
from that that point on to
it's not about me no it's about the team
what can i do for the team and then
that it sort of made me a lot better
thinking uh moving forward from there
it's like oh yeah
team first [ __ ] i was guarded
[Laughter]
but you must have gained a lot of
confidence from that tournament because
it wasn't that long after where you're
playing for wellington with all your
idols in a stacked wellington npc side
yeah that was good bro like man you know
when you play with your idols you'll be
like uh it's hard to describe unless
you've been in that position
like i was like just
looking at tana like i can't believe it
you're the man and then me training
running over them because
in a training we had to think and then
they i actually got a growling from the
boys to leave him alone i was going what
do you mean a footsteps training because
no
no
this is when you look like you're going
hard but
just make the noise you know but with
these guys you got to look after them
and then when i had a word to uh of t
later on he goes yeah just know when to
go handy and when nazi especially
as you get older
and he goes yeah i know because you're
just young and all that so energy cool
cool but it won't last
ah
then when i got older i was good see you
were right bro that's why you were the
man i know
yeah but just the look of the boys there
goes bro
but i was that scared like what do i do
what do i do what the what did i just do
i just did what the coach told me
yeah did anyone sort of help you out
through that um progression into that
side obviously jerry um you being a
party to a kid must have taken you under
his wing but any other the boys and
really make you feel comfortable in
there yeah oh so i was like uh nasa and
power was there because we went through
the uh you know the age grades together
so it was easy there and rodney as well
another guy that i
clicked with as uh as my career went on
and we ended up getting close because of
the family side of things but yeah it
was those two
but at the same time i was like you
don't want to mess with jay uh jerry
when he when he gets angry
and i was like you know you you piss
them off if he just walks right past you
i'm like oh damn what did i do
and then your mind's thinking
what did i do
and you forget about your task or what
was happening even when i came to the
train i was going
choosing for me what the hell did i do
you know just jogging and then i stuff
on my roll and i get groud off
but for the um for the coaches
and the only thing i'm thinking is i
want to get into the this guy's good
books because if he smashes me at
training
then i won't play
you know and i'm so glad that he was on
my side
because i felt his shoulders before
and yeah i never want to feel it again
yeah
never but it was good good lessons and
all that and just being honest
he is such an enforcer eh oh
one thing you told me on the bus was
just lucky i'm on your side
yep
yeah that is so true
please don't leave
please don't leave bro
so yeah just one of those blessings bro
yeah
it was your first game up against um the
british and irish lions like your debut
yeah
i was lucky enough i got on i think it
was like like six minutes or something
left and i was looking at the pictures
box and saying bro hurry up and pull me
on i just want to play i don't even care
if i get wasted just put me on
but then uh after the game my um my
coach goes oh yeah we forgot you were
even there i was going your eggs
bloody hell
i was there just because one of the boys
was getting injured one of the guys i
looked up to was joe mcdonald
he was uh he was um yeah he was lumpy
and i was getting yes at the time i go
oh yeah i'll get a half surely no
the old man kept on going
i was going right get off bro i want to
run
but you know that's as a young guy you
just want to play you really really care
yeah even then you were confident in
your own ability to perform up against
you know world-class internationals oh i
was confident because i'm i was from
puerido i had that i don't care who's in
front of me i just want to test myself
you know so that's the the mentality i
had was man i don't know what i can do
yes i can be a care trainer but
i just want to test myself against these
guys and what and also get the feel of
what the next next level is like so we
need to yeah when he got on the first
thing i want to do is just run after
people trying to hit them even though if
i was offside
i was like man come on wake up way that
way why oh man
yeah well that that mindset obviously
helped you because you did have a really
quick progression even the following
year you're into the hurricanes was it
did you notice a considerable step up
into that environment or because there's
so many all blacks for the lions back
then um was it not so noticeable uh no
not really but you can
feel the intensity um the difference
between that um from
the lions and the in the kings
the cans was just like because they
started a lot earlier we had the the
off-season pre-season
to know everything whereas the lions you
go from club rugby into the lions setup
so so that was the first thing i noticed
but at the same time was the
fitness i don't want to do this
it was like yeah and go and this is when
we had this uh one of the skinniest uh
trainers um wendell
uh andrew brembo oh yeah this is the the
guy that we all hated like not really
but you know when he trained when he had
his whistle was when he um has the
whistle
the skinniest guy
telling us big boys how to lift in the
gym
you know and then he then he comes and
smokes us out on the field and he's just
running like come on guys you keep going
kingdom and you're like oh puss off man
in our heads but at that time i didn't
want to say anything because if he says
something then i don't want to do extras
after that because i was dying anyway
yeah
but i learned to you know to respect him
and and saw why he was so hard on us was
your weight and conditioning something
you always had to try and keep on top of
yes it was um
the first couple of years uh i'll
stay within six kgs um
from you know my heaviest and my
lightest in that space but then later on
in my career i was able just to stay on
my um
my plane weight i found the plane where
i was able to give it 100 but still be
mobile and strong so that was that was a
challenge it took me a while plus that
the eating part was still a challenge
you know because oh treat yourself okay
then well my treat is completely
different to your treat
so
if i die on monday i'm gonna blame you
because you said i can treat myself
you know so yeah i was never a big
drinker you know i'll go drinking it but
i was never a big drinker but i was a
big eater yeah lots of people have
mentioned how much you can eat um you
can obviously put away a large amount of
food
yeah when i'm hungry
but i would say this and i'm annoyed
with this is i was never the fastest
there's one guy that'll be me and you
will never expect that this guy ripped
ass was the fastest leader in that team
and this is me trying to battle him
lost all the time
but at the same time it's not about
speed bro how much you can eat endurance
yeah it's endurance bro well i i was um
i don't know how i think it was jeremy
frustet told me to because it was um a
place in town hogs brief and they were
running a competition eating competition
and uh for some reason he got me in
there
went had to eat see how fast you can eat
a kilo steak so we did that i went and
joined after a minute i was already like
way in front of everyone else so i
rubbed it in by saying can i order some
fries with that please i'll just take my
time
so i still smoked the the thing and uh
in two minutes and my fries i looked
over and then the next person was i
think seven minutes
so that's when i just got up when i got
a drink came down sat down and just
waited for them and i was and then i
made it even worse by oh can i have
another one i'm starving now you know
but i was yeah [ __ ]
but then i got my you know rewards and
stuff like that you know so hey i'll
take it bro all right the kid can he and
uh a question came in about um you back
in your day uh
at the canteen did you used to polish
back some food at the canteen at school
as well
oh man now so with the canteen stuff
back then if you see somebody and this
is where we were like scavs back then
you know we'll um we'll see someone with
a pie and me and my my cousin there um
they sadly passed but me and him were
the worst ones we just look at their
person tell them man you look full
they just bought a pie right and they're
like oh so we convinced them that they
were full they'd give us our their pie
we eat it
and then we go get one of my mates um
who was diabetic um he had his mom um
in his bag was just food bro it was just
sandwiches
so we will always say to um
to the teachers oh he needs to take his
uh insulin we have to go and support him
but really he goes we follow and then we
just go eat his food
oh krakow man yeah
yeah cracked up bro and then um during
that time i was i was lucky enough i
don't know if it was just the school was
lucky but i was lucky um i worked at the
canteen
and i only lasted two weeks
oh man because the boys came or even the
girls like our two lines were a lot like
full airs the middle press uh line was
the um the owner of the canteen
and they they had no one and everyone
will come you'll probably if you came to
me you gave me five cents i'll give you
change
and i'll give you a feed for five cents
oh that's my sort of dear shopkeever
bro oh no so everyone just you just got
out of the spring oh yeah shot bro
give me another oh yeah sweet what do
you want okay sweet oh did you forget
and then i'll go you've got my change
because oh sorry i totally apologize
here
but then at the end of the lunch time
there was no food no money
and then
yeah we got in trouble so we entered a
hat um uh got told that we had to work
for free for the rest of the year oh it
didn't happen because
my mate got caught yeah my mate got
caught the i think two weeks later
so we were fired
from that place
yeah
but i will say when i when my first
paycheck with the canes i went back and
gave the uh
the money that it was taken
true
i borrowed it okay and i replaced it
that is a big play love that
the guilty conscience got you yeah
oh bro i was like six or seven years
later
sorry guys yeah remember
i borrowed this money and i ate the food
so here you can have this
okay but one thing you mentioned before
was around one of your cousins and the
passing of your cousins and mate going
through your journey and hearing some of
the stories it seems like you've been
dealt with so many tragedies um
throughout your time lost so many close
friends lost lots of good mates so and
one i don't know where it fits on the
timeline was one of your best mates at
the time i think he got stabbed or
something um brutal like that so what
what was that what how was that to deal
with and how did that moment sort of
change your life
oh man it was was huge man um so he's
he's my cousin
my second born is named after him
and he's also the godfather of my
daughter so
he was like the next best thing to a
brother to me um
losing him was
was hard
not only
at the time but even still now like
he was one of those guys that me and we
were called the twin towers back then so
if we went to a party it wasn't uh to
to mess around or just more to protect
our girl cousins that were there and
that and uh he was one of those guys
that was real
loyal to family loyal to friends and
also just a skillful guy like he was you
know he was a different person and
that's why i was attracted to him in in
that in that way of just being around
him and
learning from him and also
keeping him out of trouble if if he got
into it because like like i said with
the loyalty stuff if someone gets uh
into something he's the first one to go
in there without thinking
and
sometimes you need that but also
sometimes you just need to just hold
back and think but that actual that
that time
of my life and my family's life was it
was hard to
you know to take in because he was
massive man even around the community a
lot of people found out how he went
and wanted to come back i come down here
and seek revenge or not revenge but you
know seek justice in their own way
but it was just to see what the cops in
it did at their time
was massive because we had maybe three
or four big groups of
gangs and
big units going at it
just for one you know one stupid thing
but yeah he was bigger than life that
government and yeah i miss him to this
day
it's so sad hey so how do you know much
about the incident was it was that one
of those moments where he stepped in to
back someone up and got caught in the
wrong scene
yeah
exactly yeah it was just caught yeah um
because the the person that actually
did the you know the stabbing was more
the story we were told was he lost his
his patch or jacket whatever
earlier that night from a group
of islanders in that so they went drove
around got their stuff whatever and
thought that my cousin and our group of
mates was that group so it was just
you know wrong identity type of thing
but like my cousin there he will he'll
just go up and back up whoever's in need
and then
all this stuff happened um
along the way you know during that time
and it was until i spoke to his little
brother he was there at the time
um
what actually happened and when he told
us like a few weeks later
i was more uh broken because of what he
told me so
yeah i was like man
so there was a lot of hate a lot of
anger
at that time and
but then over the years
he was able to forgive those people and
i i was
i think i'm still not there yet as a you
know as a person right now
but
i'm just glad that you know my cousin is
has given that forgiveness and that and
it sort of made me think oh man if he's
done it then
how can i do it so now for me it's just
finding how can i forgive people that's
done something like that
so
yeah bro and how did you get back onto
your normal life like um still juggling
your footy career how did you get back
to normality oh man i think it was more
because we were you know we had a
routine you know we got given you know
the weekly plan and stuff like that so
all i had to do was just focus on that
yeah
yeah it was the hardest times was when i
was alone or like if i was driving into
training or driving back home or if i
was by myself that's the hardest time
because that's when
you know the brother
just hits you
and i just then i just thank you then
i'll have a cry in the in the car as i'm
driving and i'm like bro what you know
it's all those what ifs
if i was there if i was you know i was
yeah
so that was the toughest time um in that
space but
and then i tried to get into this uh
hooked up with what's the name of steve
simons you know at that time and we ran
a program a youth program over at tao
college
for a couple of years which just trying
to change the way the kids
see life and
try and tell them that there are there's
always
you know an opportunity
if you just seek help
but we we wanted to be there you know
the connection between the helping
and what they want to do in life so it
was yeah it was good it grew me as well
helped me grow in a different way and
see
kids
their struggles
even now
that it's just the same as everyone
else's it's just
teaching you just to be kind to people
because you don't know what battles that
they have in the background 100 mate i
love how much you give back to um the
youth and
your community it's so cool but did you
was rugby sort of like a distraction for
you was it sort of something it was like
your getaway now you mentioned the
routine of your structured week and
stuff was the best time so going to
rugby was um awesome for your mind just
to get away from it all yeah it was
it was um or something that got me up
every morning anyway like like the
environment at the canes and the lions
was was good you know it made me get up
and also just talking about
other people because the boys will talk
about their their struggles and their
and it was good to actually
bounce off them in that space and we
supported each other
and just
always like oh very if you think just
give us give us a buzz you know
not only that was
the gaming uh we were into call of duty
at that time too so
all that stuff just
took
all the all the pain in it away
i don't know if it was a good thing that
we how we did it but
at that time was
i was just trying to put her to the
cycles
it was just too hard to take in is it
true you used to um play your wife on
call of duty when you were over in south
africa and she was back in new zealand
that is good stuff if that's true
that's true
uh and we also had a um put a
a clan together so it was me my wife
nemia victor
my good mate um
spruce um anthony and his brother so
that was our clan and uh yeah we'll
smoke all these teams on the thing and
then we'll always um because my wife was
on the game she's really aggressive
you know she's the type that will kill a
lot
and she has their um
that smack talk to back it
i won't i won't say stuff because some
of the stuff was like
out of it but yeah she will she'll have
the high kills but also high thefts
whereas us we we plan you know we stick
to the uh our roles oh yeah you're the
sniper you take them out um victor and
they will be like the um the guys will
go plant the bombs
and then um
the other guy uh me and spruce will just
um
we'll just come in and back his eyes up
but if you guys die orcas will take that
kill you know
but it was always about how many
all the deaths are kills but load deaths
whereas my wife was like
1.1
but she didn't care man
so every time we come home
this was the routine we get up
go here she'll do her mom's stuff and
then get back from work about maybe 5 30
get the kids have dinner get the kids on
bed by us um
by seven and then she'll go down to our
room because she we had a playstation
down there and i'll stay up here because
there was a playstation up here and then
yep mom and dad online team her let's go
you know we jump on and we do our butt
and then that was pretty much my diet
too bro because i hardly ate you know
during that time but i was good but yeah
she was like one of those ruthless ones
that yeah and everyone goes nah your
wife's better than you
shut up i'm better look at her kd scores
bro
she's like died more than me
like i was like 1.5 but anthony was like
two point something so he was the best
out of all of us but yeah man oh i love
that but obviously it didn't affect your
form because obviously you ended up
getting called into the all blacks
didn't yeah so um tell me about that
whole experience of being called in uh
and named as an all black okay so before
that you know me and namia had a meeting
with uh the all black coaches in town in
one of the hotels like i didn't even
know what was going to happen but i got
told uh from there hey did you get a a
call from me but then um i don't know
who was the manager at the time just
said oh yeah um you got a meeting with
uh these guys at this place at this time
i said all right sweet got there
uh lucky nemu was there and then we've
got uh header meaning sat down
straight away we got growled
at by um
shag teared in and smithy
they were like ripping into us and were
like
bro i don't
i'm just here with this guy but also i
got told to come here
and i go so what do you think that you
guys can do better
how can you guys challenge each other
you know those sort of questions and at
the time i'm like
i don't care yeah i'm just listening to
my coach and i'm just doing my job but
that's what i was thinking i never said
anything
you know and then um then they just go
yep this is the thing we're looking at
you guys okay just make sure you guys
step up i think we had two more games
prior to that and then um
and that was really two good games i
played that year and and the to finish
off the season with the kings and then
yeah when i got selected um i didn't
know i got selected because i was with
jc because he came and picked me up took
me to trainings as he does and then
after he goes oh did you make it i was
good make what because did you make the
ap i don't know i'm just here with you
you told me to come with you so i'm here
and then i didn't find out until
the afternoon um after our training so i
think jerry already knew
that's why he told me to get uh go to
train with him
and then once it was uh announced but i
was passed on by one of our media guys
for the keynesian
well like it was one of those shut up
you're you know you're a [ __ ] bro yeah
you know
and then jerry just looked at me smiled
and walked away you're like bro where
are you going you're my ride
i don't know
what came with you remember because now
i'll be back right he didn't come back
until maybe three hours later but
anyways yeah i went through that uh
uh i you know it was a shock but i still
didn't believe it
so when we uh went through all that
media oh how do you feel how do you feel
blah blah
and my mom was going bro i honestly they
don't know how i'm feeling at the moment
because right now
you're still all [ __ ]
that guy my right just left
so
i don't know if this is legit normally
you'll see your name you know they'll
name it and you're there you know
because oh yeah or the the new cash blah
blah blah
and that but because i was still at
rugby league at the time
it didn't feel real yeah until i
actually um
actually put on the the jersey for the
first time when we played um uh canada
that was the time that um
i actually felt i wasn't all black
because before holding the bags and all
that stuff i just wanted to
get in there as you do yeah but at the
same time i was like far this is richie
mccoy this is dan carter oh my gosh this
car heyman
oh jerry and rodney
i was used to them anyway but
playing like being in the same team with
pretty much like
the best players in the world at that
time i was like
that was the biggest bust for me but
again the first thing they said to me
when i got into camp was okay i want you
guys talk to the nutritionist they're
going to have a plan for you and blah
blah blah
bro can you just let me enjoy this
moment the first thing you tell me is
that go see the nutritionist i don't
give a [ __ ] about the justice i just
want to
soak this thing up
you know it's like man i want to talk to
the coaches not actually to talk about
just
i just want to look like i'm talking to
the coaches but and just look at the
to see
superstar superstar superstar damn this
doesn't mean yeah you know but that's
that was the first thing finger then i
have sweet nutrition
ah man come on bro
let me live chicas
yeah so
i ate grass bro i ate grass for the
whole freaking camp bro
little bits of
of meat
yeah
and what was it like when you're out on
the field oh it's good though it was
amazing bro
it was like yeah just play a game but at
the same time you know when they when
the coaches say play your own game
you don't know if there's the truth you
know what i mean
because i'll say yeah play a game and
then if i stuff up
i'll be like you told me to play my own
game yes i lost the ball but you told me
to play my own game you know but it was
like oh man it was just a different
feeling
um uh you know i had tears and i just
figured about it
at that time and i just wanted to play
for um yes my family but i was more for
my daughter
that was because she was just one at the
time and i just wanted to
to play for her like yes i had my mom
and dad and now i'm proud of me and my
pun at the time he's my wife now
but it was the only thing i had in my
mind was praying for my daughter the man
i wanted to
to know that you know dad is doing all
this for her
and that's how i've that's that was my
motivation leaning into that to that
game and during that game as well and
you hit the rugby world cup just around
the corner at the end of that year was
that ever a motivating factor
ah to be honest but i was just i just
wanted to give them my oh if i got
selected then i'll they'll be a bonus
but i was more just
one because i was still shocked that i
actually made the the team at the time
yeah but when i was there i just didn't
want to um because of kevin uh kevin
milami was
one of my my mentors and he just told me
just look after yourself learn as much
as you can and then ask questions and
that so my whole focus was just making
sure i did a muck up
you know but i still express myself
which was when i was playing when we did
play touch and all that stuff during
trainings that was the only time because
everything was yep
hold the bag stuff this man give me a
head shield i mean you know tickle [ __ ]
i want to tackle somebody
you know but
it is what it is bro gotta listen to the
big dogs when they're in there
and what were you like in the meetings
by all accounts all black meetings are
always pretty tense and intimidating get
called out a lot
what were you like in there
bro oh
i was [ __ ] myself bro
you know because when they come in the
um the christians boys was always
sitting in the front and then i see the
auckland boys at the back so i was like
okay because they're from wanting to sit
in the middle but then um
i got told to sit in the front so i sat
just behind um the uh breath i know not
breath phone
reuben i stepped behind him yeah because
he's a big lad i was able to hide but
man just those meetings hey
oh they'll call you up big time honestly
you say whoever have been in that in
those meetings know what i'm talking
about bro they'll rip you to shreds so
what are you doing oh yeah so how come
you did this and i was going oh my
goodness
i don't know if i should be here i don't
want to be caught out like that you know
but always always out of the league and
then they'll always finish with a
positive and then they go oh yep
uh the best tackler uh bank give you a
jersey and you have to wear their jersey
um
during trainings and there so it's just
acknowledgment of your you know the past
game which is good
but
that that was like uh just learning all
their stuff was that [ __ ] i can't
believe rugby is this
i thought i was just go play
you know play hard blow well stick to
this and this but
the homework that goes behind it
is like
going back to school
got your books yep
i was pretty much just writing writing
writing looking up running down like can
you go back bars do you scared because
the the slides are going too fast
can i copy your book
bro i felt like i was back at school bro
i came here to play rugby another
[ __ ]
but you know it's just lessons bro
and this is the funny thing jerry never
had a book sure no one questioned him
yeah he'll have a notebook he'll just
come and sit down and just watch and
everyone else is like well this now
they've got ipads in there and you know
they've got apps in there
but
that sounds good bro
no one tells this guy off
no one tells you jc what to do he does
his own thing but that's that's what i
mean i said far this guy is the realest
of the real man
you're the man bro
and then um you obviously didn't make
the rugby world cup squad so how was
that to deal with did you were you
pretty gutted when that was announced
not really man to be honest like i said
my expectations wasn't uh um wasn't even
to make the aps like i was looking down
the track like a couple of years down
the track to make it
because i just wanted to establish
myself as a
starter for the lions and the canes but
so that was just like a bonus whatever
if i did go awesome
if i didn't then then i know what to do
moving forward how can i be better so i
learned a lot that yeah so when i went
back it wasn't about um
you know um
missing out it was just yep sweet i've
been here what do i do to get back in
there you know and i think that's when
my focus sort of changed how do i have
to get back into the abs instead of
how do i enjoy my rugby and if i make it
cool if that was just a bonus if i don't
it was a waste of time playing that yeah
so it wasn't until maybe
i missed i just missed out
the year after and i messed up
completely there in 2009 and that's when
uh my mind changed to
i just want to play and enjoy it and
whatever happens happens and you know
2010 and liver were pretty much my best
um
years and playing you know both for the
lions and the kings i just enjoyed it
you know it was like man who cares and
everyone goes oh yeah i want to make
babies so awesome bro
but it was it wasn't my focus it was
just
if i can play the best i can and if i
get selected cool if i don't then hey i
still got another campaign to to focus
on
so yeah man i was i was content day it
was just good that's it so then the move
over to france
uh what was the reasoning behind this
one and where how did that one come
about um
well i spoke to colin keeper like a few
years back um i just said i'll stay here
as long as you're here
and then i'll go after that because i i
knew i wanted to go to france anyway
because all the boys were going yeah man
go to france go to france oh yeah yeah
yeah as you do but then it wasn't until
um
i had my kids at the time one was
uh i had a one-year-old or a
three-year-old and a five-year-old so i
thought this would be a good time just
to go away
um maybe two three years whatever and if
we ended up staying cool if we came back
in cool you know
i was more i was still young enough to
go away and then come back if i had to
and
when we went it was
honestly
as a family that was the best time of
our lives just to
spend more time with family
together because we had no one else to
you know to count on but ourselves we
met some amazing families over there got
to see the world in a different space as
well
the rugby was crap like it wasn't up to
the level of how we were here
and that but it was uh it was different
but you know the family life was amazing
you know and i got to see
my wife and like the the person i saw
was the person i fell for you know back
in the days
yeah um
yeah so she came out of her shell which
was cool my kids were um growing up
there was
i had my two translators my daughter and
my son
because i still crap at it
and yeah and then yeah it was just
it was it was goody it was mean i
wouldn't change i won't change that for
anything it was i think it was just the
best time to go and the best time to
experience it with my family at the time
before you left had there been another
tragedy with your niece yeah would that
be a part of the move um
not really
uh
it was more
we were already planning on on leaving
at this time that's what i told my agent
that the year before to start looking
um but that was yeah that got me good um
you know my wife's family good because
she came down here just to visit us you
know just after new year's and she was
meant to stay and her sister for a
couple of weeks
and then that happened yeah i was just
out of the blues man um
went down took my daughter's bike
because i was just going to the to the
shops just to grab something because we
just got back from the lagoon with the
kids
and i was just going there to grab maybe
ice blocks and whatnot and then
and tragedy happened bro and
i was
i was like i was frozen man i was like
what the heck just happened because it
just happened within seconds bro were
you there yeah we were um because she
was just going of with the kids and my
wife and his brother and i was here with
the sister-in-law and and the baby we
were just like
just in the lounge and
all we hear was screaming you know like
what the heck
and i and then next minute ringing the
ambulance and we were trying all we
could to you know
revive her in there but
it wasn't to be man and that was that
time i was
praying my my ass off i was like man
please just bring her back whatever i
just want a miracle blah blah blah
yeah i was
and also at the same time to me i was
thinking probably not again why this is
yeah
too young like i was like man
she
she was an amazing kid too you know
um
and just to lose her that way and the
fam and my wife's family at the time was
like
i just couldn't um
handle it and then if i was and i was
just thinking man imagine if that was my
my kid
you know how much
pain and suffering the parents would
have lived through i was like man
i don't wish that upon anybody you know
you normally i just want people just to
grow old and go you know the right way
you know live your life and there but
not at that age so
well again i was just lucky enough with
the boys that you know at that time all
the support that you guys gave and
i was
yeah that was my strength too because i
was struggling
i was trying to be strong for my um my
wife and her family in there but at the
same time i was like
the hell am i gonna do you know how can
i support them and if i'm weak but all
the messages and then because i keep
strong blah blah oh man cheers bros
so i was good
and then that year was like yep i knew
this was going to be my last year here
so i'm going to give it all i can for
the boys and
whatever happens happens so
yeah well it's so strong to be able to
get through all those tragedies and um
you know stay so positive and
keep playing so well yeah
well it was just more
just remembering my mum just to always
keep my faith but this is all my aunties
and all the females in my family hey
they're they're crazy they're either
the punisher the sheriff
or your you know your god-saving
person to get you out of anything
so they were always hard with church and
and god and all their stuff and always
told them just
always have faith
stay positive positive side was the
hardest part but
it was just you know just
saying i'm not here for me i'm here for
the boys and the boys will be here for
me so i want to make sure i show up and
show them bro i'm here i've got your
back let's go let's go
you know so
yeah i'm just lucky to be in a
supportive environment so
you know i was just blessed love that
and so you said you you obviously loved
your time over in france your family
really grew and um
flourished over there and then you came
back to new zealand came back to the
hurricanes what was the reason behind
that move unfinished business or um
you'd had enough of france uh it was
unfinished business but also it was just
the rugby i honestly didn't enjoy it
um they said they when i got there i was
there was some stuff i was like they'll
scrum
just to get a penalty instead of
bro let's attack we got firepower like
honestly that team that i was with um
they could play but they weren't given
the chance to play i was like oh let's
scrum
oh hell no let's go line up get close
bang let's unleash you guys and then it
was like day for two years and i was
like
bro i don't want to be doing this i want
to enjoy my rugby you know and
um yeah and the team was struggling as
well i think they're getting close to
relegation in there and it was just more
do i leave now or do i just stay but
then you know hammer at the time um
gave me a little offline to come back so
i took that and
just enjoyed whatever i did back at home
back you know back in france and then
when i got back i just wanted to try and
get myself back into the you know
the shape i wanted to to to play and
compete but
my mind did change i was like nah
i just want to be here to support the
boys and all the the props at the time i
just wanted to be like just to guide
them as much as i can like i honestly
didn't care if i if i played or just
what can i do my my time and the game is
is running up what can i do to help
benefit the lads
and then one of us to compete at
trainings and the others was just uh
try and get them to to be the best they
can be and
lucky enough i had um reggie goods at
the time but he was a great player good
player man i'm just glad that he had to
retire due to concussion but
he was an up-and-comer we had ben franks
that came up from the crusaders and
um jeff was there as well so we had a
good bunch there um but again it was
just more
how can i support these guys and i was
already looking
forward to the next part of my life
anyway if it was like two three years
down the track
so be it
mate that's what i remember about you
obviously when you did come back how
much of a t-man you were always giving
what you could to the side and like a
lot of people say they didn't care if
they were selected or not but you
genuinely look like you were there no
matter what um to help anyone you could
and um share on your knowledge that you
did and i know being good mates with
reggie how much he got from you and um
all those other props have kicked on to
have some pretty um successful careers
and i think you're a big part of that
oh just a little bit oh she's more me
just yeah i just wanted them to be the
best because i mean i've uh when you see
uh amazing telling us that imagine if
you harnessed it in the right way i
still don't know how to do it myself but
you know i was just
giving little tips here and there and
then just going through through their
motion but yeah i enjoyed it that's when
i sort of
started enjoying the coaching side of
things
so i was like oh yeah this could be
something i can do but i just looked at
my kids
how can i coach my kids but you know it
was mean that was me some good stories
along the way that's why when i look
back at it
i'm glad i saw what i saw and did what i
did with the boys they saw them
what stupidly stuff they you know all
that bro what the heck but at the same
time we're so lucky we didn't have
social media back then as well
if this came out you will be on your ass
contract ripped i don't know what the
hell you'll be doing but you know
i'll just yeah it's funny when i look
back at it and me and the boys catch up
and talk about some of that stuff
because remember this just
not today not today
oh yeah some good times so then why did
you have to retire um was that an injury
forced retirement yeah it was
um uh 18 months prior i had
i got blood clots uh block clots or
blood clots fresh deer um and my lungs
and i was but i didn't know at the time
uh so i played maybe three or four games
with it
um and the year 2014 and my last game
was against the crusaders when we just
won down there and not a party scored in
that corner
but i was like the whole game because
jeff got injured and i had to freaking
play the rest of the game
and
yeah oh i was struggling and then the
boys will go man you look unfit work on
your fitness okay bro you know how hard
i work bro
like those they know me oh no i'll train
until i'm gone
but it wasn't until my wife kept on
telling me go get checked okay i have as
a chest infection
and then got checked
uh i found out we had blood clots
i didn't know what that meant they just
said lucky didn't go to my brain or as i
would have been dead
holy [ __ ] okay that's strike one yeah i
know that was track one and then i got
it again later on that year
and then if i got another strike three
then i would have been out in terms of
um playing
play my first game against taranaki um
and this is when broadly got injured as
well
so this is the sig yes it was the same
game
he got a concussion i ended up getting a
brain bleed but we didn't find out until
five days later again my wife
go get checked nah nah nah i'm all right
let's go doctors now i'm all good i'll
be right in the next minute had a scan
and lucky enough um their meer sister
was um one of the um
one of the nurses sort of must have saw
how i was fast tracked my
um my scan got it done yet got brain
bleed lucky i came in that time because
if i came in later on who knows what had
happened i was going
[ __ ] that strike too
so yeah
and then
yeah later in that week um steve simons
and brody came to see me at the hospital
and i was like off my facebook
i can just
hear them and
because you know when you have a
concussion or you know some type of
brain injury
um your senses uh your senses you know
heightens big time i can hear them
coming down the hallway and it's like
maybe 50 meters away
but yeah that's what i said now i'm done
that's when i knew
i don't want to go through this again
because if i do or if something happens
who's going to look after my kids
you know even though they're the you
know life insurance and [ __ ] but
they won't have the debt around so
that's when i caught it yeah no no hey
sarah
that's brutal that's quite scary hey um
if you hadn't checked yourself in how
brutal that could have been oh well
that's the thing when i ask in fact
strike two already
the hardest part was um just telling my
daughter my son at the time
because that's not plain anymore and
then my daughter broke down and then i
think oh my son goes
why aren't you playing what's wrong with
you because uh that's brain is useless
at the moment
and plus um you know all this other
stuff so yeah did that and then um later
on um so that was it retired from rugby
completely but then lucky i i did
three months i had a blood test and they
said i got the syndrome that um will
cause your blood to clot
um right through so now i'm on blood
finish for the rest of my life
oh you know how long i have left yeah so
that's why i gotta watch uh any type of
contact um physical stuff even at the
gym i've got to be careful on
what i do any cut or end up bleeding out
so
hey
i was gonna put cotton wall on me yeah
so that's the thing you go from a guy
that like loves his ruxin you know
all the contact to don't touch me don't
hurt me
i might bruise easily
you know so
yeah did you miss that
yeah i was going to say do you miss how
much do you miss rugby yeah i must have
bro yeah i must
i was telling my my phys yoga bro i must
have taste the blood i miss the smell
that the feel of you know your body saw
because you've earned that right to be
so you know yeah and also the
camaraderie and all that stuff um
yeah i missed all that bro so
i can always um i'm slowly getting back
to into like talking to people and that
like you're like yourself than that
because prior to that the first couple
years like i hit rock bottom like i was
depressed i was in there
i didn't give a [ __ ] anymore type
because uh not because i retired it was
just because i couldn't do what i wanted
to do you know i wanted to be a police
officer leaving forth after i left so i
was already looking to the next part of
my life
now that that sort of stuff
so
yeah so i don't know what to do until
you know i got some help and
they sort of guided me into into what
i'm doing now so
you know just just lucky bro but
rugby will
is the reason why i'm still here so
you know i always say i'm blessed
because two strokes bro i would have
been on the ground
so how you mentioned um obviously the
mental health issues how did you get
through that part because obviously it's
a hugely common part of society these
days lots of players even are struggling
with it
lots of guys suffer from it post footy
um in that transition
how did you deal with it
i was put on a program
from um from new zealand rugby but i was
lucky that they got me with a
psychologist but also got me a physio
type
uh slash
trainer because talking to somebody is
one thing but actually getting in and
doing something in terms of exercise and
all that and having someone there
talking to you encouraging you telling
you to do this and why not to do that
that was the thing that got me through
and the last 18 months has been
the best
i've had because of those two uh two
guys um they were always in my ear
telling me you know what to do
encouraging me to just to give things a
go
not not uh
not uh yet go
100 because when i did get told that
like a couple years ago i went for a run
at the lagoon just down the road i ended
up falling into the lagoon because i
went too hard
i said oh no you but you told me to go
ahead
go 100 i was going
yeah
so what happened because
i saw my you know where the the track i
was on and then next minute
my vision went that way and i ended up
falling into the bloody lagoon but yeah
there was like a a mum with the dog and
they just helped me up and i was going
now you know sir
sorry
but really bro my my vision went like
this and then just
okay yep so i told my physique you're an
idiot
but when you tell me to do something
i'll do it yeah so if you tell me to go
100 100 i'll go 100
now i was like no no we'll start at 50
51 52
there bro
oh mate it's so good
oh but good to hear that you're um in a
good space now and um obviously giving
back all you can to the community and
obviously you're a great dad you've got
three very talented children who no
doubt new zealand will be probably
seeing a lot more of over the coming
years
well good luck to them as long as they
listen man that's the only thing because
these days man you tell them what to do
and then they're like
uh okay okay i'll tell you now because
i've been there done that yeah just shut
up and do it
chicas because oh but you know ah shut
up
i'm learning i'm learning my template my
fees is like
yeah oh my as we all are mate kids uh
kids are challenging there's no question
about that
but as always we have gone to our
instagram for some questions and um
there has been some good questions
coming for you so we will try and rattle
through these
first question this one came up the most
that was uh very common
pretty much goes like this
uh what does aggression look like john
whoever said that i'm sure is one of the
boys and i'll tell you now boys stuff
he's all but i'll tell the story anyway
okay so this is what happens so this is
in um 2008 okay uh we were going into
the all black camp
uh we did our trainings and then we had
one-on-ones right
and then
i had one it was my turn when
nervous as bro i took my book as if it's
gonna be a session
first thing they tell me was oh what can
you bring to the team
i was like
what
i don't
so i was like i was like thrown back
right there because i was going why are
you asking me
why am i here you know that's that's
my thinking and then they go um and i go
oh
oh um
a christian
and then uh
shay goes up what does that look like
oh [ __ ] i was being attacked thinking he
was just joking i went huh
just as a jerk
and then i go no no you know i mean um
like christian into those into the
contact you know
hit them and all that you know i've
learned how to be good at cleaning out
um and just being really physical and
stuff like that and as i was talking and
saying that chrono
senior was like like that
and then
and then that went on did my thing
walked out okay
the [ __ ] did i do that for
and then the first person i was told was
name because he was there right it was
my roommate
i went in i was going [ __ ] [ __ ]
i guess what my weapon
that's bro i can't believe the breakers
sorry what happened
oh man sorry i was at that bird
okay brotherhood you know when you say
brotherhood to the boys
they that means brotherhood you know you
got your back all this the word bro i
support you because yeah brotherhood bro
okay sweet i told him what i did
he goes oh yeah
and then before he got up just to go to
the toilet the ducky had
opened up the door and closed it as you
went and he was all you hear that
and then he ran and all you hear was
brax wax but he went and told everyone
so by the time i got to the team room
the striker room all the boys are giving
me [ __ ] guys what does a question look
like okay
nasa you dick you said
[ __ ] brotherhood because you know no
i say brotherhood no you said
brotherhood no brother her
and then lawaki one of the biggest
mockers in in life you know before he
passed by he was just giving me that and
he gave me all these different
expressions of what it looked like and i
just cracked up ali williams gives me
[ __ ] too and everyone's going are you
serious good bro no i honestly thought
it was a trick question
so because i was i didn't understand
what they were telling me i just thought
i'd be a dick and do that
which in reality
it made me look stupid but at the same
time because i'm ted um what's his name
and smithy was just like sitting there
like this and chrono because he was at
the back he was
just doing that i was going oh [ __ ] so
when we had our um
our scrum session later on in that week
he goes
are you right
yeah what's up
there's just your um your one ones
because oh no no oh i just i don't
understand the question
and then he goes oh okay cool
just um
okay let's go
okay oh [ __ ] man be chronic i was just
okay nevermind move on but because of
nemir the idiot
he goes and tells everyone and then any
time i'm in like uh any whatever team
i'm in because all i heard those are
remember what does that christian look
like i look at them again you [ __ ]
dick
why did you tell them that
doesn't mean to be between us and this
is where i would never ever trust your
ass ever again
stuffy bro
and we still talk about it now
because remember oh here we go
i'll try grab the closest thing and try
and throw it out of me
oh so good
obviously everyone knows about it now
because that question came in so many
times in different formats
i knew that was going to happen yeah
because that's what i got from some of
my um um
messages too is that what does the
question look like and then i'll just
give him your finger or just uh hahaha
but really shut up
you went there
oh
that's a that is a good yeah good stuff
i love stuff like that okay next
question what happened at new zealand
under 16 when you filled your plate with
food oh who the hell ty if this is you
you're a dick bro
so this is um again
bro
you're in the environment you're like
[ __ ] can't believe it this is amazing
with the institute of rugby and palmy
and you know when you see food all lined
up it's like yo
time to eat bro
but then you see all these guys having
little like little like small plates
food i was going what the hell how new i
grabbed the biggest plate there
and then i'll go and it was like a
smorgasbord bro
oh yeah oh this this this so my plate
was like this like with the food
it was like a freaking pyramid but
and then i i saw me and the other guy uh
drawn off well we smoked it
we smoked it and we went for seconds
because it was heaps of food i was like
wow this is going to be a waste
a win up and then the stick and stuff
and then the manager bro grab real
fingers what are you doing
no that's enough just sit down you
already have the brother i was going
what the hell where's this gonna go and
then the boys behind me
just saw that and they know oh yeah
sweet so they would they acted like they
weren't gonna go for seconds and they
put um there was like a tray that you
put the um your your other plates on you
when you're finished they took that i
turned around those game
you guys don't
take it for the team
take it for the team and that's when i
knew all right sweet
don't eat too much or i'll just keep it
down and then i can go for seconds as
long as it's not a permit
so many lessons wow
but they blame me for it
okay next one what did jerry collins say
to you before every game
oh
don't disappoint me
get to him and then guys don't
disappoint me
okay okay
oh damn man how can i not disappoint you
he just put more pressure on me [ __ ] man
yeah but that's what he who always type
or he'll just give me the look and you
know what the look means
you know yeah
because there was one time we were i
think we played the waratahs
uh they kicked it um cliff
palu i think was his name their number
eight
he ran it and all i could hear behind me
was jc
smash him take his head off
and then i'm like what the hell so
instead of there i just made the tackle
right yeah and then after they when i
caught up i looked at him because i must
have been a penalty he looked at me and
all he said was i [ __ ] told you to
smash him
okay
he ran away
i had to run after him
so that's why we like yeah so that's
what he will tell me either give me the
eyes or tell me that disappointing
oh he was sounds like such an enforcer
he would have scared the [ __ ] out of me
playing with him
oh i was scared just being in the same
thing because they're we stuffed up i
have to go sit somewhere else
okay next one um this one's from our
sponsor swish if you could get a video
shout out from one celebrity who would
it be and why oh
i'll go with
denzel washington he's the man oh
yeah
he's the man he's the
he's the god of all the type of actor
he's the man all of his movies man
does it really well he's got that style
he's got their swag so if it was anyone
will be him you've even got the denzel
um goatee going on too yeah because
that's all i can
great for i'm not like all you guys that
can freaking grow all these bloody
things so every time we go to south
africa we have to have facial hair
i'll go and i was lucky enough when i
when you're over 50 games you don't you
can choose
but man because you've got to grow a
beard bro i can't grow a beard
so i always hated it yeah same here okay
two more best andrew horse story he
seems to come up a lot throughout the
waterland episode so surely
you got a good one
okay i got two of them i got one
we were in africa
it was a day off
um
well i think we're playing the shacks
right and he goes oh yeah let's just
have a drink so it was just more us
tidies um so it was
pig um nasa annette so we just went down
to the
the um hotel bar
had a few
coops comes down sees us jelly and he
goes oh this is amazing
cool enjoy your night
and then that was the go the okay for
hurry goes up this this drink
it goes oh
we got training oh we had a day off but
he goes oh we got training
he goes no i'll be right
but no one drinks like that guy so we
honestly must have went through maybe
a few dozens
maybe more
but that's so um i woke up
i was had i think it was like one
o'clock the next day
and then um bro i know and then ask and
he he was just walking around like it
was nothing and then we trained on on on
thursday captains around on friday and
then we played i think the sharks i
think but me and namir was like [ __ ]
how can we do this we have to play well
or one we gotta get dropped or two we're
never gonna drink again like this yeah
after the game first thing he goes is
let's do it again
that i ain't going to do that bro
i'll hate this [ __ ] bro because i don't
know how you can do it but i can't do it
yes no no there's team bonding coups he
loves it he loves they were like
connecting in there stuff like that i
was doing yeah my connecting is
different to your connecting i can't
connect like this bro
because i wouldn't last
and he did that and then
the other story was when
um kimberly we didn't play that game and
um um those deities had to go to uh do
some fun activity when he took me up to
the shooting place
on his farm and um he was teaching me
how to shoot right
thinking that eye sweet because i was
like man this is the real life call of
duty stuff you know i've got a sniper
blah blah blah
the neck minute
he so he's just showing me all the stuff
but what he didn't tell me is you know
the scope
yeah it has to be far
not close to my eye
so okay cool
so we were practicing some shooting blah
blah and then we went out actually and
he i shoot there um i don't know it
looked like a freaking big deal
some sort over there
and then i go oh yeah sweet and i gotta
kill it because yeah bro i was nervous
as here because i've never killed
something you know i shot anything any
neck minute finger on the back of the
truck
and i went to shoot
and i thought i got it
but at the same time the scope bang came
up put me in the eye
and then i go [ __ ] did i get it because
yeah you got it and then i looked and
there was dust so i i shot these um
i don't know if it was like termite um
things whatever it is but that's what i
shot because there's heaps of them
around
i guess no you got it that's good whoa
the man i thought it was because i i saw
the actual deal on the ground so i
thought i shot it but it was the um the
guy that owns the ranch he shot it
he was my my backup
so here's me thinking farm the man with
a freaking like
thing around my eye
and thus coming up and then he was just
telling me oh bro you're the man that's
good and he was rubbing it in and then
it was until the guy told me the truth
and i honestly i was gonna flip but not
shoot hurry but i was gonna hurt him
with the gun okay you're a dick right
this is your stuff
let's go
stuff you bro
never went hunting again
oh never went hunting again bro because
i don't trust this guy hey
because every time
okay no i don't trust you i don't know
if you're telling the truth because he
says stuff like a straight face so i
don't know if he's joking or what yeah i
was getting that one i left there with
my dignity on the ground
dust
floating
and the freaking thing around my eye
but lucky i it wasn't it was far enough
that it didn't like break it because
they said if it was real close i would
they would have taken my eye out
but he was just standing there just
laughing his head off
wow
i would have lost my eye
oh bro you're a dick bro
oh the yarns i love it okay
good stuff last one
best piece of advice you have for
woodland listener
love to finish on something
inspirational and mate you're an
inspiring guy
if anything just
take everything that comes your way you
know if it's good or bad it just depends
on how you react to it as long as you're
positive about it
then you you'll be you'll be fine you
know because you'll get heaps of
challenges along the way and it's just
how you react to it
just yeah
that's how i'm looking at things i love
that mate and you've obviously had to do
that you've had so many ups and downs in
your
life already and um just the way you've
been able to confront those challenges
and um enjoy those uh good moments has
been impressive to watch and maybe it's
been awesome to have you on the podcast
to be able to go through all that and
hear your full story and um some of the
good yarns you've had throughout your
career and post footy as well yeah oh
good bro now pleasure and awesome uh
thanks for having me bro it's good to
actually catch up like this and that but
yeah
if you get the rest of the boys and
moving forward just make sure that
they keep their stories to themselves if
it's about me too
hey you're lucky i don't tell you so all
these other ones okay
shut your mouth
nah watch yours brother no i appreciate
it mate i'm sure a lot of people would
have got a lot out of that
cheers brother
[Music]
what
[Music]